digamos que tengo dos compartimientos de
agua separados por una membrana
semipermeable ahora a qué me refiero con
membrana semipermeable bueno es una
membrana que permite pasar algunas cosas
y otras no digamos que esta membrana
semipermeable si permite pasar moléculas
de agua y justo aquí voy a tener un
montón de moléculas de agua y en unos
segundos hablaremos de lo que no permite
pasar lo que la haces semipermeable pero
primero pensemos que solo tenemos agua
en ambos lados como ya lo hablamos en
los vídeos de difusión
debido a que tenemos la misma
concentración de moléculas en la
izquierda que en la derecha la
probabilidad de que una de estas
moléculas esta se mueva hacia la derecha
en un cierto tiempo es igual a la
probabilidad de que una molécula de agua
ésta se mueva hacia la izquierda y esto
porque tenemos las mismas
concentraciones y porque todas estas
moléculas se están moviendo en distintas
direcciones ésta se mueva para acá
para que tal vez ésta se esté moviendo
para acá está para acá pero todas se
están moviendo en distintas direcciones
y con distintas velocidades
cada una tiene distinta velocidad y cada
una tiene distinta dirección solo
tenemos que pensar en términos
probabilísticos ojo la probabilidad de
ir de izquierda a derecha a través de
uno de estos huecos bueno es exactamente
la misma que la probabilidad de ir de
derecha a izquierda y pasar por uno de
estos huecos en un cierto tiempo dado
ahora bien es el momento de hacer esto
muy interesante vamos a pensar que esta
agua es un solvente y pongamos algún
soluto en ella vamos a disolver un poco
de soluto por acá y bueno voy a hacer
este soluto mucho más grande para que de
una manera física te des cuenta que
tiene problemas de pasar por estos
huecos que tenemos aquí también existen
otras maneras para tener membrana
semipermeable es por ejemplo algunas que
usan carga eléctrica
a permitir o no el paso de las
partículas y de hecho de estas
hablaremos más adelante pero es más
sencillo visualizar este tamaño y que te
des cuenta que este soluto no va a pasar
por este hueco entonces lancemos un poco
más de soluto por aquí voy a tener otro
por acá otro por acá otro por acá otro
por acá y también por aquí voy a poner
uno o dos pero lo que sí quiero que veas
es que hay una mayor cantidad de solutos
del lado derecho que del lado izquierdo
otra por acá y otra por acá date cuenta
que estas grandes partículas no serán
capaces de atravesar esta membrana por
estos huecos lo que quiere decir que no
serán capaces de difundirse si se les
permitiera difundirse sólo se moverían a
favor del gradiente en cualquier momento
dado recuerdas tendremos una mayor
probabilidad de que una de estas grandes
partículas se muevan de derecha a
izquierda que de izquierda a derecha
porque hay más moléculas en el lado
derecho que en
izquierdo estás de acuerdo pero esta es
una membrana semipermeable lo que quiere
decir que estas partículas grandes no
podrán difundirse naturalmente de un
lado a otro
todas estas partículas grandes tienen
sus propias velocidades tal vez esta se
mueva para camps tal vez esta se mueva
para camps tal vez esta se mueva para
acá o esta para acá pero lo que quiero
que pensemos es qué va a pasar ahora
primero pensemos un poco el problema
sabemos que las grandes partículas no
pueden difundirse de un lado a otro pero
qué va a pasar con las moléculas de agua
las moléculas de agua del lado izquierdo
no van a ser detenidas y si se mueven en
el camino correcto ellas podrán moverse
de izquierda a derecha atravesando sin
ningún problema estos huevos pero que de
las moléculas del lado derecho bueno si
está en las condiciones adecuadas puedo
decir que esta molécula de aquí va a
poder cruzar sin ningún problema del
lado derecho al lado izquierdo de esta
membrana entonces definitivamente
tendremos moléculas que se estén
moviendo de un lado
pero puedo argumentar que existe una
menor probabilidad de que las moléculas
de agua del lado derecho se muevan al
lado izquierdo que viceversa y por qué
es esto por toda la interferencia que
provocan estas moléculas grandes que no
se pueden difundir todas se estarán
moviendo y algunas veces estarán
inclusive bloqueando el paso puede ser
que haya una molécula de soluto grande
justo aquí te das cuenta si la membrana
no estuviera aquí bueno no bloquearía el
paso y entonces ellas seguirán
moviéndose pero como la membrana está
aquí pueden bloquearla y tal vez después
de bloquearla pueden rebotar y ésta se
vaya para acá y mientras rebotan puedan
empujar alguna molécula de agua
imagínate que aquí tenemos una molécula
de agua y al chocar con esta que tenemos
aquí entonces cambia de dirección se
puede argumentar que algunas de estas
moléculas de agua seguirán yendo de
derecha a izquierda pero hay una menor
probabilidad de ir en esta dirección que
de izquierda a derecha y debido a todo
esto tendremos una entrada neta
de agua proveniente del área donde está
la baja concentración de solutos a esta
área donde hay mayor concentración del
soluto recuerden un producto es lo que
está disuelto en agua así que este de
aquí este de aquí es nuestro soluto
soluto y bueno el solvente es aquel que
está en mayor cantidad en este caso
nuestro solvente es el agua así que lo
voy a escribir
este es nuestro solvente solo
entonces el soluto se disuelve en el
solvente y así tenemos una migración
neta de moléculas de agua de esta
solución la que tenemos a la izquierda
con una baja concentración de soluto a
una solución con una alta concentración
de soluto ya este fenómeno le llamamos
osmosis déjame notarlo
este es el fenómeno que se le conoce con
el nombre de osmosis
si también existen otros ejemplos para
ósmosis es algo que hemos observado
muchas muchas muchas veces estoy seguro
no sé imagínate en algo que está
acostumbrado al agua dulce y tienen piel
o membranas que permiten el paso del
agua y después ponlo en agua salada vaya
problema como esas cosas famosas
llamadas babosas que no les irá nada
bien en presencia de la sal porque el
agua dentro de la babosa hará lo mismo
que sucede en este diagrama ahora esta
es una explicación de la que acabamos de
hablar sobre el fenómeno de osmosis en
donde tenemos moléculas que no pueden
pasar a través de la membrana impiden
que las moléculas del agua vayan de
derecha a izquierda seguramente estas
moléculas de soluto rebotan y
posiblemente causan que las moléculas
del agua se muevan en esta dirección
esto cuando el chocan con solutos otra
explicación es que muchas veces el
soluto que ha sido disuelto en el agua
tiene una carga eléctrica asociada a él
cuando pensamos en sal de mesa
es habitual tenemos cloruro de sodio
pero cuando se disuelve en el agua
tenemos en primer lugar unos iones de
sodio los voy a poner aquí y iones de
sodio con una carga parcial positiva
mientras que también tenemos iones de
cloro déjame ponerlos así con una carga
parcial negativa los iones de sodio son
positivos y los iones de cloro son
negativos y este bloqueo va a ser
distinto al bloqueo mecánico del que
acabo de hablar existe la idea de que
debido a que estos son guiones y tienen
carga eléctrica hacen que el agua que
tiene carga parcial se pegue más a estos
iones y cuando el agua se pega a ellos
los iones no serán capaces de atravesar
esta membrana a qué me refiero cuando
digo que el agua se va a pegar a estos
iones bueno veámoslo así cuando pensamos
en una molécula de agua hay un oxígeno
por aquí que por cierto tiene una carga
parcial negativa y ya este oxígeno está
pegado a dos hidrógenos estás de acuerdo
un hidrógeno por aquí otro por acá
tiene una carga parcial positiva
entonces tenemos que el extremo del
oxígeno que está un poco alejado de
estos hidrógenos será atraído a las
moléculas de sodio ahora a simple vista
vemos que el sodio no pasa a través de
la apertura de la membrana ahora
imagínate que estos amigos en el agua
quiere pegarse a este don de sodio
entonces es mucho menos probable que
pase a través de esta membrana y que
estas moléculas del agua pasen también a
través de esa membrana de manera muy
similar si tienes unión con carga
negativa entonces ahora podemos orientar
al agua de esta manera aquí voy a tener
al hidrógeno y por acá voy a tener al
oxígeno donde los extremos del hidrógeno
tienen carga parcial positiva carga
parcial positiva y van a ser atraídos a
lyon cloruro que tenemos aquí como el
ión cloruro no puede atravesar será
menos probable que estas moléculas que
están pegadas a él atraviesen también es
decir que estas moléculas van a ser más
atraídas por el ión cloruro o por él
de sodio que por las otras moléculas del
agua que solamente tienen cargas
parciales y me encantaría si alguno de
ustedes me mostrara alguna simulación de
esto que estoy diciendo o a lo mejor
creamos una en el programa de ciencias
de la computación de khan academy para
mostrar justo este mismo proceso de
ósmosis es decir que tenemos una mayor
probabilidad de que las moléculas de
agua de aquí vayan de izquierda a
derecha que las moléculas de aquí vayan
de derecha a izquierda debido bueno
puede ser al bloqueo mecánico y todas
estas grandes moléculas rebotando y
empujando las de agua en direcciones
contrarias o porque las moléculas de
agua estén pegadas a grandes moléculas
como estas que tienen una carga
eléctrica y esto es
oasis